I'm Uchiyakuba skipper with Sea Scout Ship 272 in New York City, New York.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old Scout Master.
Our senior patrol leader asked one of our scouts if he would like to be the troop historian.
but the scout wouldn't do the job because he said there was no future in it.
So next he said, well, how about being the bugler?
but apparently that wasn't noteworthy enough for the boy.
So finally the scout accepted the job of being the troop librarian
and now he is in charge whenever there's a hardcover warning at camp.
That's a threefer for you right there.
Hey, this is podcast number 322..
Music
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
As always, let's take a look at the mailbag.
Last month I put some t-shirt designs up for sale on Amazon.
Some of you have seen them, some of you haven't.
Look in the podcast notes.
I'll have a link where you can find those.
I just wanted to share some reviews that we got about the shirts,
And the most popular one is one called Stuff. Scouters Say,
which is like more than 200 things that you probably end up saying over and over again.
It's all printed on the shirt.
It's just a lot of fun.
In the reviews, people have said it's a great shirt.
All the scouts and leaders in our troop got quite a charge out of it.
It was a terrific gift for a long-time scouter.
I bought this for our past Scout Master of seven years,
who probably has heard 90% of the sayings
And he wore it at Wood Badge Training.
It was definitely a conversation piece.
So when you get a chance, check them out.
Mark Lee is the Conocohe District Chair in the new birth of Freedom Council
in South Central Pennsylvania
And he wrote in to ask: is the Scout Master CG app coming back?
Well, no, Mark,
I announced in January we're going to kind of let the app go by the wayside
and focus resources and time on other things.
So no, the app is not coming back.
It's no longer available.
It's not coming back,
But we're still alive and well doing podcasts and blog posts and things like that.
So every week, try and have a couple of live chat sessions,
usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Keep an eye on my Facebook feed and the Twitter feed for an announcement
when we will be live at scoutmastercgcom
and come and join all the folks that check in for a chat.
A lot of folks that check in we call frequent fliers,
but joining them this week was Jeffrey Heck,
who's an assistant Scout Master for Troop 56.
Rob, who's an assistant Scout Master for Troop 235
in North Plainfield, New Jersey.
Darryl Oakley checked in and he's a Scout Master with Troop 132
and Upton, Massachusetts.
And Don C checked in and he's a Scout Master too.
Sometimes we talk about really important things and sometimes we just talk.
That's live chats, scoutmastercgcom Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Watch the Facebook feed,
Watch the Twitter feed.
Come and join us.
We have a lot of fun.
Hey, if you're a regular reader and a listener,
I have a favor to ask of you.
What you need to do for me is go to scoutmastercgcom.
Look in the upper left-hand corner of the website.
You'll see a menu there.
Click on the support link and take a look at the opportunities
to become a Scout Master CGcom backer.
The funds that we get from backers go to support the work
that we're doing and make all of this possible.
And then you'll also see a link titled Be a Patron.
That'll take you to something called Patreon
And through Patreon you can make a monthly subscription payment
of $5 or more if you really enjoy the podcast
and all the other things that we do,
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Robert Williams,
who's become a patron since last week's podcast.
Take a little time this week to figure out
which option works for you
And I'll be sure to thank you personally
on next week's podcast.
Well, in this week's podcast,
oh, I've got a couple of brief email questions to answer,
But in Scout Mastership, in seven minutes or less,
something that will phrase as youth engagement in scouting
and explain exactly what I mean by that.
So, hey, let's get started, shall we
Scout Mastership in seven minutes
Or less?
So, when we're really hitting on all eight cylinders,
scouting is something that Scouts do for themselves
rather than just like this program of activities
that is presented to them.
There's a big difference there, right?
If we are just putting together a series of programs
and activities that Scouts participate in,
they're not really fully engaged in what's going on
and we're not really tapping the potential
and the opportunities that scouting presents to us,
Because the context of scouting means our youth members
are engaged in leading one another
and in making decisions affecting what they do
and how it's done.
I want to call this youth engagement
rather than youth leadership-
And I'm being pretty careful about the terminology here.
I'm saying youth engagement,
I'm not saying youth leadership,
or boiling it down to that famous two-word phrase-
boy led-
And the reason that I think we need to differentiate,
because a lot of times we look at youth leadership
as kind of like a light switch:
It's on or it's off.
We're boy led or we're not boy led.
Now what we need to do is to engage all of our Scouts
in a partnership where they're leading one another
and they're making decisions affecting what they do
and how it's done.
Our ideal role as Scouts is being a barely perceptible influence
that empowers young people to do things for themselves,
And we accomplish this through a kind of a progressive partnership
of adult and youth roles that are collaborative
and not necessarily hierarchical.
Now, there's a couple of great $9 college words right there.
So what I'm saying is is that we are facilitators,
enablers, helpers, mentors, guides, coaches.
We're not issuing orders.
We're working with our Scouts in a way that they are fully engaged
in what's going on.
And this partnership, this kind of collaborative partnership,
is one of the unique facets of Scouting
that adults generally misunderstand.
We can be very reluctant to put trust and authority
in young people or doubt the ability of young people
to exercise that trust or that authority responsibly.
But engaging young people in these things
does not mean just purposeless anarchy.
I mean Scouting has boundaries. in the same way
the lines chalked on a playing field
describe the boundaries of a game.
Both Scouts and Scouters observe the boundaries
and we have a shared commitment
that's based on mutual trust and patience.
And that's why, as I said before,
I want to be really careful about the terminology
and call it youth engagement rather than youth leadership,
because it's not this kind of binary, on-off thing,
It's progressive.
We could do a much better job
of building that progression in early on,
when our young people are in Cub Scouts
And the opportunities are there
but they're not necessarily connected
with what happens in the future.
We want the youngest youth we're working with,
helping with simpler tasks and some decision-making
and peer-to-peer work and sharing
and helping each other right,
And we build on that by giving them
more directive leadership roles
and intermediate tasks as they get a little bit older,
more influence on choosing activities
and decision-making and instructing
and leading each other,
And then we build that towards more independent
decision-making and leadership roles.
This progression, if it hasn't started early on
or if it's just simply not present
with the youth that we're working with.
it's going to take some time for this to all catch,
for everybody to understand their roles
and things to get going.
And there's a real simple kind of three-step formula
for this by Greenbar Bill William Hillcourt
in an earlier Scoutmasters' Handbook.
Very simple idea:
Train them, trust them and let them lead.
So let's pick that apart for a moment.
Training,
So we wouldn't begin instructing Scouts
learning how to tie a square knot, for instance,
with long theoretical discourse on knots and rope.
We put a rope in their hand and we let them try.
So if you're going to engage youth in leadership,
the most effective way to develop those skills for them
is by getting them to lead,
And that's engaging them in actual
rather than theoretical leadership,
because leadership skills develop as you lead,
not in a training session or in a theoretical environment.
And we have a way as adults a lot of times
of over-explaining and over-instructing
in a way that our Scouts find very frustrating.
So let's not overload them with theoretical information.
Give them the basics and let them at it.
Follow up with reflection and mentoring
to steer developing leaders towards more confidence,
more success and more understanding.
Training our youth members to be engaged
with what they're doing is not an event.
It's not something that we can sit down and do
with PowerPoint slides or in a theoretical environment.
They have to actually start doing things
and then, once they've done them
and they've had a little experience, reflecting on them
for a very short period of time
before they move on to the next challenge
is a really great idea, because then
they start to understand the complexities
of what they are doing.
So the next thing Green Bar Bill says is
trust them, says train them, then trust them
and think about this. okay,
Maybe you haven't had the pleasure yet,
but if you have a child, at one point
you're probably going to get involved
with helping them learn how to drive
and get a driver's license.
And if you're going to ride along in the car
with them as they're learning,
you know what I'm talking about.
It's very challenging
to put a whole lot of trust
in what they're doing,
and letting scouts engage in leadership
feels a lot like sitting in the passenger seat
while a student driver steers the car.
Now we may understand how important it is
to let go, but letting go is never easy.
Trusting youth leaders is always a challenge,
but it gets easier as you see
what they are capable of achieving.
And next is: let them
Let them lead.
So we can't give scouts the responsibility
and then undermine it with continual interference.
And that interference can come in many guises.
It can come as wanting to help,
or wanting to instruct or train,
or just being a little anxious
about letting them carry out
a given activity.
So it's real responsibility
and letting them lead
and letting them learn
as they move along.
So let's talk about real responsibility,
and real responsibility
means that we haven't eliminated
all the possibilities of failing
in the situation.
I mean, we want our scouts to succeed, naturally,
but this doesn't mean we absolutely
protect them from failing.
We ought to expect and learn to welcome
all the little bumps and setbacks
and failures that come along the way,
because they're a vital tool
for developing skill.
If you think about it,
any skill that you claim right now
you develop by making mistakes,
And the wonderful thing about scouting
is that we put our young people
in a safe environment
so that they can make plenty of mistakes
and thereby learn and develop some skill.
Any championship sports team
has usually suffered at least
one or two losses somewhere along the way, right,
And the difference between a championship season
and a losing season
kind of hinges on learning the lessons
from those losses or those failures.
Handled the right way,
All of the things that go wrong
can be a source of intense motivation
for athletes and for scouts.
We need to respond to mistakes and failures
with good humor and encouragement
and commiseration, because we've all been there.
We need to understand
that failures and missteps are inevitable
and they're valuable
and they're opportunities to grow.
They're not crimes to prosecute and punish
And we can encourage leadership, development
and accountability
without being real dramatic
or having to deal with punishments or bad feelings.
And the right attitude on our part
will inspire the initiative in our young people.
And that attitude can be a real challenge
as an adult, because a lot of us have tried
at least once or twice or three times
to engage scouts in meaningful leadership
and if they don't respond as we'd hoped,
we get impatient and discouraged
and we tend to reserve important decisions
and authority to ourselves
because we know that we tried that a couple of times
and it doesn't work.
Look, scouts are no fools.
They will wait until you do everything for them,
because in a lot of ways
that's normally what happens
in just about every area of their lives.
But we want to inspire them
to take the initiative of making things happen,
and we have to understand
that what might seem routine to us
may be totally new
to one of the young people that we're working with,
and I think it's unfair to expect
an inexperienced scout to respond
the same way an experienced adult would
when they're faced with a leadership challenge.
And scouts always show initiative
if we learn to look for it.
Sometimes it's very small,
but when anybody is undertaking a new enterprise,
like engaging themselves in leadership,
they are vulnerable.
They need reassurance to get past
their problems.
So instead of looking for what's wrong,
we do a lot of work looking for what's right.
We look for the least sign of initiative
and we support it and we build on it,
no matter how small it might be.
So we want to watch how we react
to what scouts do
and we want to find that kind of advisory role
and that advisory voice.
And I'm not talking about tone or volume,
but the motivation behind what you say.
If you're really
invested in engaging youth in leadership,
you will help articulate
the concerns of all the scouts,
to motivate your youth leaders to service.
So let me explain what I mean by that.
Why are we engaging youth in leadership?
Is it to satisfy the demands
that we're making on them? No,
They aren't serving us,
they're serving their fellow scouts.
And what do their fellow scouts need from them?
They want to go camping
in advance and do scouting with their friends. right,
An advisor is keeping that
in front of the youth leadership all the time.
Hey, you're serving these scouts.
what do these scouts want?
Are you making it happen for them?
You're not serving me. I'm not your boss,
I'm not your drill sergeant.
You're serving your fellow scouts
and I'm just here to help you make that happen.
So this whole concept of engaging youth
and the way that the opportunities we present
for them to develop leadership skills
needs to be a progressive thing.
and then the work that we do
with them to advise, to instruct,
to mentor, to coach, to guide-
are things that are simple to articulate in a podcast,
but they're very complex things to learn
and it takes time.
So you have to be patient with yourself too,
because in scouting, the relationship
of adults to youth leaders
is something that you will not find
very often in the other endeavors
that they are undertaking during this time of their lives.
So, as you go out and you work with your scouts.
think about youth engagement
as a way of helping them develop leadership skills.
E-mail, that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your e-mails.
Sean Earp is the Scoutmaster, Troop 330
in Auburn, Washington,
and he wrote with this question. he says:
sometimes, as a new-ish Scoutmaster,
I'm finding it challenging to figure out
why our troop does things the way that it does.
Is it because the previous Scoutmaster
preferred to run things that way?
Is it a question of policy?
Is it a
Or is it a question of
policy?
Or is it some kind of inviolable precept
handed down by Baden Powell?
For example, when we go camping,
our patrol is set up and camp and cook
as a patrol, separate from the adults.
But I'm trying to figure out
where do the senior patrol leader
and assistant senior patrol leader
set up their camp and eat?
As long as I've been with our troop,
the senior patrol leader and assistant senior patrol leader
have been required to set up their tents
and eat with the adults.
So I wanted to see if that's the norm.
I see no guidance in any of the literature,
not in the troop leader guidebook
or the Boy Scout handbook
or the senior patrol leader handbook.
Sean, that's an interesting question.
I'll tell you: my practice has been
to have those youth leaders
who are not in a patrol camp
and cook with the adults too.
Now, we don't require them to
by any means,
It's just an expectation that has been created
by long practice.
I know that it should be,
as really never come up recently,
but that would probably be a really good thing
for you to do with your youth leaders
is to sit down and ask them
how they see the issue
and if they want to change the way things are done.
They may come up with an idea
that neither of us have thought of.
Daryl Oakley is the scout master,
Boy Scout troop 132 and up in Massachusetts,
and he wrote with this question.
he says: I've been through youth protection
a couple of times.
I'm one contact role.
I understand that when I email, text
or otherwise contact a scout,
there's always a parent
or a scouter included in the message or conversation.
I know when I have a scout master
conference, I do it in plain sight of others.
but what happens when I pick up
the phone and call a scout?
Do I have to have like another party
on the line with the scout in myself
If a scout asked me for a merit badge counselor
and he calls the merit badge counselor
should his parents be listening
to the phone upstairs.
This is all really kind of confusing.
Well, Daryl, yes and no,
I mean, you have it right.
There's no one-on-one contact.
Just keep that in mind and keep it simple,
and it's really not all that confusing
when you think about it. You're on the phone
with a scout. think about it
in the same way that you would think
about talking to a scout at a meeting
or during a scout master's conference.
We don't go into the other room and close the door.
No, we do it out in the open
or we keep the door to the room open or whatever.
So you pick up the phone and call a scout
and his parents pick up the line.
Hey, I wanted to talk to your son
for a moment about scouts. Would that be okay?
Are you making a one-on-one contact there?
Well, you're talking one-on-one with the scout,
but somebody else is aware that this is going on.
So you call on the phone
and the scout picks it up.
You say, hey, I wanted to talk to you
about a couple of scout things.
Is your mom or dad home? Could you put them on the line
for a moment, Or you are
someone else's presence when you're making the phone call
and you say, hey look, I'm going to call John.
He's our senior patrol leader.
You don't have to listen in,
but just follow my side of the conversation
for a couple of minutes, if you would.
I hope that helps clear the confusion up.
but that's usually the way that I observe
the youth protection thing. when it comes to telephone calls,
I make sure that there's a third party involved
somewhere and that they know
that that conversation is happening.
Hey, if you have a comment or question,
I'd love for you to get in touch with me.
I'm going to tell you how to do it in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening to this 322nd
edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast. Here's how to keep in touch.
Go to scoutmastercgcom.
There's like 1,600 articles
and over 300 editions of the podcast there,
And you can subscribe to receive updates
by email. You can also
follow us through social media. There's
14,000 folks who like Scoutmaster
blog on Facebook. We have,
of course, the tweeters on Twitter.
Hey, if you've never checked out Pinterest,
you can pin the Pulter Tunis pictures we
propped for publicly with a passable of prolific
pictures on Pinterest. You can watch our videos
at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
but if you can't face Facebook
and Twitter makes you better. if you've
no interest in Pinterest and you don't
put the? U in YouTube, well, that's alright.
Just zoom in to the late 90s
and fire off a good old fashioned email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark
Green, at Clark at
scoutmastercgcom,
C-L-A-R-K-E
at
scoutmastercgcom.
If none of that works for you, the next time
you're out camping, wait for
the sun to go down, gather your fellow
scouters around a magic mirror, repeat
ScoutmasterCG three times
in unison and I'll
make sure to answer any
question you might have. Well,
by this time it should be abundantly clear:
the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications of anyone
in particular other than myself,
And I am not endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America or any
other scouting organization for that matter.
It's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and have
a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking
of fun, here he is
our founder, Sir
Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir?
Until next time, everyone.